[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
this one is over it's official it is
history for the Princeton tigers for the
first time in school history Princeton
is going to the Sweet 16. just the 4th
15th seed ever in the history of the
tournament to advance to the round of
16. Princeton 78 Missouri 63.
Princeton knocked off Arizona then
Missouri Princeton has Creighton coming
up on Friday and their head coach in his
11th season Mitch Henderson joining us
on the program
are you surprised that uh you guys are
going to Sweet 16 or how surprised are
you I'm I'm surprised I would be lying
if I wasn't so good to be with you by
the way I'm such a big fan of your show
um but the guys aren't I think that's
the key that's why we are where we are
and the other thing I will tell you you
know we don't have any transfers you
know that sort of the thing in college
basketball it's a it's really a
homegrown group one through you know
first year through fourth year and
um they're really close and tight-knit
group so um we had a guy on the team
that speaks Chinese uh God I can tell
you every flag in the world by taking
thermonuclear Dynamics uh so they're
they're they keep each other humble and
they have a really good time together
and I think that there's
there's something special as you know in
March when that happens but coach do you
do you Embrace Cinderella or do you try
to you know give it the Heisman no way I
think you got to embrace it right like
um we love you know we have a really
cool fan base here at Princeton a
passionate fan base about their school
um and they love being you know they
love the attention so we're we're
embracing it I think it's you know
that's key especially on Friday night we
play a 905 game get get them nice and
Rowdy and embrace the uh the
improbability of it have a lot of fun
with it
can you outsmart teams and I'm not
playing to the cliche of Princeton and
you know obviously the academics here
but
can how does that help you as a coach
I don't I don't think I mean you know
certainly thinking now of Creighton I
don't think you're outsmarting anybody
um although I would say that you know
savviness
High skill level a commitment to doing
the things that you need to do to win
um and then you know we have a group
that's willing to do those things I'm
not to me that's being playing really
good basketball it might be considered
smart but you know more just just more
possessions try to have more possessions
in these games
yeah you just gotta win one and then you
get you get the next one so I I don't
know that that's smart to me then I'll
yeah I think I'll take it uh how often
do you go back to 1996 with the upset of
UCLA when you were playing it for your
team like how much do they know about
your role back in 1996 not rarely thanks
for asking that and rarely I for me I
don't think it's wise to talk about your
playing days although that picture's up
all the way all over the place here I'm
right here in the gym I can't wait to
take that thing down and put some
Arizona photos up
um you know all the parents when they
come on their visits they're like we saw
a picture of you downstairs boy you
could jump high and I was like not
anymore you know
um and you know you want for your team
for them to have their own memory and
they have that now and I never went to
the Sweet 16.
um I'm so happy for them and our school
is too
and sometimes the team doesn't change
but the people around the team change
that now all of a sudden you know you
got everybody's attention whereas before
they're probably like uh you know
probably gonna be a one and done but hey
we got to the tournament yeah now it
feels like the expectation level has
jumped quite a bit here good why you
know that's why that's why I'm here
um you know coach Carroll passed away
this year and we've been honoring coach
this year but he'd be the first person
to tell you he wanted Princeton
basketball and and we always have
thought of ourselves as we have been a
nationally relevant Powerhouse program
that hasn't been the case in terms of us
making the sweet 16 but why not let's
let's keep it going you know let's let's
move the needle here and keep pushing it
how do you recruit against other schools
I mean so first we cast a huge wide net
in terms of grades that's the first part
then we aim for the top 20 best players
with grades in the country
and we're really simple really up front
we tell them all about what it's like to
be a student athlete here and again I
mentioned to you you know Donna team
speaks fool in Chinese and wants to be
Secretary of the State and we celebrate
those things Dan we talk about it all
the time like um I don't think there's
any hiding from that that parents
entrust us with their kids
to say to the kids now you're going to
be great at both school and basketball
our guys are in school today
and my parents did that and it changes
your life and um it's a it's it really
changes your life forever and we talk
about that openly and some people like
it and others want something else and I
think that's the other part is also
saying no to families to moving on in a
situation where it's maybe not a great
fit for you or the family because
there's an unrealistic expectation that
you know you're not gonna
you're not gonna maybe be willing to do
everything you need to do to be a
student here at Princeton because that
that's the expectation but with the
amount of money that's in college
athletics now and I don't do you guys
have uh nil money at Princeton no not it
not it not the way other schools do we
we have sort of a very different way of
looking at it
it's legal now it is you got an
endowment that I think could buy you
probably a national championship team
yeah but you don't do that no and you
know that endowment serves it's a very
important purpose to the school and
that's that's far beyond me
um what we do talk about though is
um the enriching experience of the four
year you know we don't have graduate
school you know professionalized
graduate school here at Princeton you
know no med school no law school we
really love and dive in on the four-year
undergraduate experience the
relationships professors and you know I
know you could I I know your sense of
humor a bit you know you'd be like well
show me you know where's the money you
know
um but it's it's we really dive in on
the experience the whole experience for
the student athlete and uh I think
that's enriching in its own way now look
like we're in the sweet 16 so there's
some opportunities for our guys going
into this weekend that they can take
advantage of we're talking to the
Princeton head coach Mitch Henderson you
you grew up though in weren't you in
Lexington
I was did you grow up in Kentucky did
you want to go to Kentucky Well I grew
up in Vincennes Indiana and there's a
junior college there called Vincennes
Junior College then we moved when I was
12 to Kentucky and patino was the coach
and believe it or not I on my Junior
High basketball team was Heath Willard
who's the head coach at Maryland Gigi
Smith
um Bobby Smith's kid who was you know
just was at High Point and and
um Aaron Van Horn who was a head coach
at Northern Kentucky that all these you
know the Willard and uh Smith dad's real
assistant with patino I mean everybody
wanted to play football you know this
was 90 1989 90 when when that that
really good Kentucky team was forming it
ended up taking Duke to the final game
so yeah I wanted to go I wanted to play
for Patino
did you cry after Duke beat Kentucky in
uh the tournament with Christian
Laettner shot
when uh yeah I was I was you know what's
funny I was at Princeton on my visit at
the national end when uh Leitner made
that shot I didn't cry but but I was so
in love with that team uh Richie farmer
Darren Feld house fell free uh Sean
Woods made a runner to put him up one I
loved that team and I I was I used to go
on the driveway and practice that Sean
Woods Runner all the time I hated
leightner just like you know I wasn't
crying what if Leitner said hey coach
I'd like to talk to your Tigers before
they play Creighton I would I would
gladly welcome that you know I loved
that did you see that I hate Christian
Laettner yeah I thought that was great
and you know I hated him because I was a
kid I didn't know anything different but
um he was a killer I would love to have
I would love to have him talk to the
guys I I loved you know he's you know
not everybody loved him but he was in
such a great basketball player
you know you get in these moments and
Rick or um uh John Calipari talked about
this after the loss to Kansas State he
said not everybody's built for this and
he was talking about players
how do you know if your players or
player is or isn't ready for a big
Moment Like This
we were at Dartmouth best way I can
answer it February you know 11th we had
a bad game
and I went into the locker room and I
lost it and you know as much as I can
lose it and I was like you know we got
back
to Princeton and I was like don't ever
let that happen again you know and
you're what you're thinking about in
that moment is
we don't we don't have it we don't have
it and then and then and then we did all
of a sudden we did and in February and
that's
and then and then this weekend it took
on a whole new level all of a sudden we
were close with Arizona we didn't lead
until a minute left in the game
and the guys were they were just
shouting non-stop we would come back to
the Huddle and the guys were just like
we got this we got this and it was
unanimous all the way around it was just
constant chatter
and if we had lost the game I would have
been so proud of them but then it took
on a whole other level and it's just
it's just grown during the Missouri game
they were on fire not just making shots
they were having the best time ever
totally responding to the moment
okay be honest with me with family
members filling out a bracket how many
had you beating Arizona to start out
um just my 10 year old son
but he had he has us losing in the sweet
16 I mean this morning at breakfast he
goes I'm regretting that decision
well it's a great ride have fun and uh
do you have your speech ready for Friday
yeah yeah uh no not quite ready you got
anything in mind
oh gosh
maybe you go herb Brooks you know the
U.S Olympic hockey team yeah yeah you're
going to remember this for the rest of
your life come on why not you know I I
think there's some good belief and uh
and thinking why not why not us so and I
do love that slogan why not
yeah and it's you got to believe in
yourself before everybody else is going
to believe in you and and uh you know
that's what got us here honestly so why
not keep that going don't try to be
something you're not
uh is why not us is that proper grammar
I don't I went to Dayton so like I'm not
I'm not the right person I'm in coaching
I did I did by the skin of my teeth what
were your SAT scores I don't remember
that and you know everybody remembers
perfect
I was on a show the other day and they
were like hey we knew some you know they
were not too long ago they were like you
heard you had a 4.5 at Princeton and I
was like off by several points
so but I'm really happy to be here and
uh I work at the best school in the
country Dan and I'm so thrilled to be
representing us just remember coach C's
get degrees
yeah a friend of mine used to say d
equals diploma
uh play some D against Creighton and
they got some guys who can score 30 on
you but um congrats so far good luck
okay thank you very much that's uh coach
Mitch Henderson Princeton head coach
11th season there